[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
conquering the West required a great
deal of force settling and pacifying
this vast area required a great deal
more violent actions were usually the
prelude to the achievement of social
stability
they've been romanticized for more than
a century in the fiction and folklore of
the West first came war against Mexico
in 1846 to 48 and recurrently through
the 19th century against the Native
Americans the United States even tiptoed
to the brink of war against Britain in
1846 and again in 1859 over where to
draw the boundary between the United
States and Canada on the Pacific coast
before finding a way to resolve the
question diplomatically most of the
western territories endured a phase of
vigilante justice in the years before
attaining statehood during which
suspected criminals were hanged or
flogged by angry mobs hatred of ethnic
Outsiders especially the Chinese was
another source of violence as was
retaliation against theft finally as the
scale of Western mining increased so did
conflict around the mines with strikers
fighting pitched battles against
employers private armies against
Pinkerton detectives and against strike
breakers most sections of the western
frontier was settled disproportionately
by men first with women following later
and gradually redressing the population
imbalance a combination of factors led
to the men being heavily armed first
they were displacing the former
residents usually by force or by
coercive treaty arrangements with the
Indians second they often supplemented
their diet by hunting and had learned as
boys how to shoot
third they bore the memory of their
forefathers the American revolutionaries
who deceived independence through their
willingness to fight and win after the
1860s they also bore the more recent
memory of the Civil War in which great
cities and armies north and south heeded
the call to arms and
and how to use guns and fourth the
generation that settled the plains and
mountains states came of age in the era
of inexpensive mass-produced firearms
notably the Colt revolver and the
Winchester rifle which made the
ownership of weapons easier and cheaper
than ever before foreign travelers to
the West between 1860 and 1900 often
mentioned how many men were armed and
that they displayed a prickly sense of
Honor
backed by bravado and courage these were
of course the kind of conditions that
made violence common and often lethal
settlement of the Far West was slow and
sparse in the early years of the 19th
century though the handful of white
mountain men were themselves masters of
the rifle the sudden rush to California
in 18-49 was something new population
rose they're much faster than the local
authorities ability to deal with the
problems the gold-seekers nearly all men
brought with them these were the perfect
conditions for vigilante justice to
arise in the gold camps hundreds of men
living and working side by side feared
that the gold they found might be stolen
when they discovered a thief they often
created ad hoc courts heard the evidence
and dealt summarily with the offender
the punishment was usually flogging or
banishment but if the offense was more
serious the offender was hanged even so
the mining camps moved as quickly as
they could to formalize legal
institutions create courts and elect
sheriff's travelers who were impressed
by the presence of guns were also
impressed by how men from back east had
brought with them the civic and
Democratic traditions of their homes and
the camps and in the port city of San
Francisco whose population was also
growing at breathtaking speed vigilante
justice was also popular at first
newspaper editors supported it as the
necessary response to what would
otherwise be chaos and brute force
they also appreciated the fact that it
saved the nascent community a lot of
money and time the speed and ferocity of
vigilante punishments was designed to
have the strongest possible deterrent
effect for example an Englishman named
James Stewart traveled from Australia
which was then the site of a large
British penal colony to the gold rush
camps of California he was suspected of
a series of thefts and then of killing a
merchant in 1851 the San Francisco
vigilance committee seized him it was
organized by Sam Brannan a Mormon
businessman and one of the wealthiest
men in the city hundreds of supporters
of the committee poured into the streets
as news spread of Stewart's arrest the
local sheriff lacking manpower to take
the accused villain away from the
vigilantes made a feeble and ineffective
protest before Stewart was marched down
to the harbor and hanged in public
California's governor approved of the
action when an indignant judge impaneled
a grand jury to indict the ringleaders
it refused to do so several of its
members belong to the vigilance
committee a few weeks later the
committee attacked the city jail seized
two other men and hanged them both
despite the authority's attempts to
protect them the committee abolished
itself after three months out of
deference to due process but it
reconvened in 1856 and undertook for
more lynchings again with a high degree
of popular and press support public
demonstrations and pseudo military
regalia the states and territories of
the plains and Mountain West showed
comparable patterns of vigilante justice
well - feared that the gold dust they
were painstakingly accumulating might be
stolen cattle men had to be vigilant
against the threat of horse and cattle
thieves Theodore Roosevelt was
expressing a fairly common opinion when
he wrote that in the early days of these
ventures vigilante justice and even
vendetta's were defensible as soon as
the communities become settled
begin to grow with any rapidity the
American instinct for law asserts itself
but in the early stages each individual
is obliged to be a law to himself and to
God his right with a strong hand in 1863
Bannock a remote community in Montana
territory was plagued by a gang of
hijackers who attacked gold convoys and
stagecoaches
seizing property and killing travelers
the citizens of Bannack and those of the
nearby settlement of Alder Gulch created
a vigilance committee of their own only
to discover that the criminal mastermind
was their own sheriff Henry Plummer
Henry Plummer was an odd many-sided
character extremely hot-tempered who
over the years had shot and killed
several men in barroom brawls originally
from Maine he'd made a fortune in the
California Gold Rush and been a
successful businessman but then gone to
San Quentin prison for murder released
after winning an appeal claiming that
he'd killed his victim in self-defense
Plummer migrated to Montana made a good
impression on the local people and won
election as sheriff as in San Francisco
the Montana vigilantes who organized to
a post Plummer acted in broad daylight
they seized one of his gang George I
eaves and cross questioned him at an
outdoor trial that lasted for three days
despite icy winter weather and was
attended by hundreds of local gold
miners at the end of the trial he was
summarily hanged the committee went on
to round up the other members of the
gang lynching 20 men including Plummer
himself in January 1864 another Montana
vigilance committee led by Granville
Stewart and known as Stewart's
Stranglers hunted down cattle rustlers
across the territory
one of the territory's richest Ranchers
Stewart was enraged by the theft of a
prize stallion and 35 cattle his
vigilantes killed a large number of
thieves variously estimated at between
twenty and a hundred nine men died in
one incident the Battle of Bates
point in 1884 when Stuart's men set fire
to the cabin in which the rustlers were
sheltering and shot them down as they
emerged from the flames
he later justified his ruthless approach
to law and order in a book forty years
on the frontier and he retained a
reputation
not for lawlessness but for being one of
Montana's leading pioneer citizens
President Polk Grover Cleveland made him
the United States ambassador to Uruguay
and Paraguay in neighboring Wyoming the
Johnson County War was one of the more
famous conflicts of the 1880s and early
90s in which both sides accused the
other of theft large cattle ranch owners
said that small ranchers often the
Cowboys whom the large ranchers employed
in the annual roundup
were stealing unbranded or maverick
calves as a way to start herds of their
own obviously a newborn calf is not
branded which creates an opportunity to
claim that it's really a stray or wild
animal that somehow become mixed with
the herd the small farmers responded
that the big men who are monopolizing
the land of the public domain even
though they did not own it both groups
were smarting after the severe winter of
1880 six to seven which had killed tens
of thousands of cattle on the open range
the Wyoming stock Growers Association
representing the large ranchers and able
to dictate rules favorable to themselves
at the territorial legislature finally
hired a group of mercenaries from Texas
they arrived in the area in April 1892
with a target list of men to kill the
local men turned the tables on them
almost at once besieged them in a cabin
and exchanged gunfire for three days
before a troop of US cavalry arrived to
separate the two sides ironically the
local county government was so poor it
could not afford to bring the
mercenaries to trial and most of them
were simply permitted to leave unscathed
small businessmen were also matched
against a big corporation in the muscle
Slough conflict of central California
homesteading farmers in Tulare and
Fresno counties in California's Central
Valley we're told in 1879 that their
claims were invalid and that the land
they were farming actually belonged to
the immensely wealthy and politically
influential Southern Pacific Railroad a
judge found in favor of the railroad but
the homesteaders rather than accept the
verdict fought back in a gun battle of
May 1880 in which seven men was shot
dead five of the surviving settlers
served jail terms were acclaimed as
popular heroes on their release a year
later those who died took on the aura of
popular martyrs the railroad prevailed
in the long run but already unpopular is
sank even further in public esteem it
was the villain of Frank Norrises novel
the octopus published in 1901 when two
bandits Chris Evans and John Sonntag
began robbing trains in the early 1880s
they were acclaimed as popular heroes to
well-known writers of the era Joaquin
Miller and Ambrose Bierce wrote admiring
articles about them in the San Francisco
Examiner as the historian Richard
Maxwell Brown explains the anti railroad
law breaking of Evans and Sonntag was a
surrogate for the seething resentment
towards the Southern Pacific by peaceful
law-abiding Californians the incident
and the publicity it generated had an
effect on Theodore Roosevelt among many
others in his approach to restraining
the power of Monopoly corporations
incidentally train robberies are a stock
theme in western movies the very first
recognizable movie Western was the Great
Train Robbery from 1903 a moment's
reflection will show that in reality
they cannot have been easy to carry out
especially if the train was moving
passenger trains full of men many of
them likely to be armed with dangerous
targets even for gangs who did manage to
bring them to a halt Train Robbery
certainly did happen especially in the
30 years before 1900 the notorious Jesse
James gang
carried out at least four in the 1870s
and Butch Cassidy carried out a famous
train robbery at Wilcox Wyoming in 1899
but statistically they were fairly rare
banks were much easier targets
stationary more likely to be full of
money and more compact no wonder they
were far more often the scene of Western
robberies another frequent scene of
violence was the cow towns of Kansas
where the Texas cattle drives of the
1860s and 70s ended mayhem often ended
when Cowboys rode into town and cut
loose after months of solitude on the
trail the city certainly wanted their
business but knew they had to police the
Texas Cowboys by disarming arresting or
if it came to the point shooting them if
they got out of control while Bill
Hickok was the sheriff of Abilene Kansas
in the early 1870s and once killed a
Texas cowboy named Phil Coe that was the
exception rather than the rule
however the historian Richard white
notes that as the cowboy towns developed
so their sheriff's worked out methods to
encourage a respect for the law and to
restrain violence as he writes although
restricting possession of handguns
remains an emotional issue today
nineteenth-century cattle town residents
resorted to gun control without much
hesitation Wichita and other towns
outlawed the carrying of handguns within
the city limits and established police
forces to patrol the towns and enforce
the ordinances he goes on to note the
extreme rarity of man-to-man gun duels
sheriffs and marshals rarely faced down
gun fighters but they regularly knocked
down and dragged away drunks controlling
and disciplining the inebriated was in
fact their main duty he also notes that
in the atmosphere of the late 1860's and
early 1870s there was some residual
civil war tension in the cow towns the
citizens tended to be former union
supporters while Bill Hickok himself
came from a family of abolitionists
whereas the Texas Cowboys we usually X
confess
Hertz in cases of vigilantism the
perpetrators clearly had an idea of
justice and believed that they could
achieve it only through collective
public action the same was true of the
IRA's periodic race riots in which the
anglo-saxon majority proudly declared
its racial views then attacked members
of an ethnic minority group especially
mexicans Chileans and chinese california
in particular had been the scene of
large-scale Chinese immigration from the
gold rush years onwards many more
immigrants came from China to build the
Central Pacific Railroad in the late
1860's providing a welcome source of
labor to Leland Stanford and the other
railroad entrepreneurs working-class
whites bitterly resented them for the
economic competition they offered for
their willingness to work for low wages
alleging also that they were klemish
addicted to opium dirty and dishonest
the California workingmen's party led by
Denis Kearney was explicitly
anti-chinese as was the supreme order of
Caucasians a white supremacist group
widespread anti-chinese racism led to a
ban on Chinese voting in the California
Constitution of 1879 then the Chinese
Exclusion Act passed by Congress in 1882
the onset of economic hard times the
next year led to further scapegoating of
Chinese workers in 1885 white mine
workers in Wyoming went on strike
against the mines owner the Union
Pacific Railroad in response to a
threatened pay cut when the Chinese
workers of Rock Springs refused to join
them
the whites rampage through the local
Chinatown killed about 30 men and drove
hundreds more out of town and into the
mountains Seattle and Tacoma to
Washington towns on the Pacific coast
also endured anti-chinese riots which
amounted to a campaign of ethnic
cleansing Street mobs forced several
thousand to flee in 1886
ten gold workers in a nearby camp who
tried to stay were murdered the next
year the worst violence in Western
history apart from that of the Indian
Wars involved clasp conflict at metal
ore mines and coal mines mine owners
tended to be tough hard bitten
entrepreneurs with a broad streak of
ruthlessness working conditions were
chronically unsafe in their minds death
from fire from collapsed tunnels and
from gas inhalation were common to make
matters worse the mine owners rarely
paid their workforce in money instead
they paid the man in scrip a kind of
private currency that the workers were
forced to redeem at company owned stores
where prices were high and quality low
in remote mountain districts the workers
also usually lived in company housing
which made them exceptionally vulnerable
to the will of the mine owners they
reacted by creating unions the hardrock
workers who mined metals formed the
Western Federation of miners and the
coal miners formed the United Mine
Workers the unions campaigned for safer
conditions a Czech way man to ensure
that the ore and coal they brought to
the surface was being weighed honestly
an 8-hour workday and collective
bargaining rights for the union's
themselves the owners fought tooth and
nail against the union's fearing loss of
control and loss of profitability if the
state authorities and the local
community supported them the men that
could sometimes win their strikes that's
what happened in [ __ ] Creek Colorado
in 1894 when Governor Davis weight sent
in the militia to safeguard the miners
and when most of the townspeople agreed
with the strikers cause weight belongs
to the radical populist party and at one
election the previous year just as the
Great Depression of the 1890s began he
visited the scene of the strike and
persuaded the owners not to extend the
workday from 8 to 10 hours with no pay
increase as they had in 10
later governor's Republicans and
Democrats more often sided with the mine
owners from inclination and from fear
that strikes would damage their state's
reputation for business governor James
Peabody for example issued court
injunctions and sent in the state
militia to help the mine owners when the
[ __ ] creek miners struck again in
1903
this time the union was defeated many of
its leaders were expelled from the
community and the company hired strike
breakers instead neither did the mine
owners hesitate to infiltrate the
union's with spies and to kidnap beat up
or intimidate particularly dedicated
union leaders state support for mine
owners proved decisive in Idaho to a
trainload of miners dynamited the
factory of the Bunker Hill mining
company in 1899 because the company
refused to recognize the Union the
structure valued at half a million
dollars was completely demolished in the
blast the Union had used dynamite in an
earlier strike of 1892 to destroy an ore
processing plant at the town of gem and
remembered the spectacular effects of
this tactic this time around however the
company retaliated by persuading the
governor Frank's TuneIn burg to call on
the president for federal troops who
arrested nearly a thousand miners they
were herded into enclosures known as
bullpens and left there for months with
no due process some were stranded for
more than a year when a local newspaper
editor criticized the situation his
paper was closed he was accused of
sedition he was forced to join the
suffering men in their vermin-infested
makeshift prison this collective
violation of the miners civil rights
broke the Union one of the miners Harry
orchard later assassinated governor
student big feeling a particular sense
of grievance because student berg had
originally been a populist elected
largely with miners votes
orchard also suspected that the governor
had been bribed by the mine owners to
change sides a sense
a tional trial ensued in which orchard
alleged that he'd been hired by big bill
Haywood and two other leaders of the
Western Federation of miners Haywood was
an anarcho-syndicalist who did believe
in class warfare and was willing to use
violence to smash capitalism he was one
of the founders of the IWW the
Industrial Workers of the world
America's most revolutionary trade union
in the short term however Haywood was
vindicated thanks to the courtroom
performance of his attorney Clarence
Darrow the jury found him not guilty
whereas orchard went to prison for the
rest of his life escaping the death
penalty only because of another
governor's grant of clemency the most
violent episode in the Western mining
patches came in 1914 during a long
winter strike in Ludlow Colorado and
mines owned by the Colorado fuel and
iron company this was an area just north
of the New Mexico line in which the
unions have previously been defeated by
a combination of employer intimidation
use of injunctions and the militia and
by the employment of strike breakers the
strike breakers themselves a decade
after their first arrival on the scene
were now as burdened as the men they had
displaced and finally rebelled against
oppressive working conditions in
September 1913 many of them were recent
immigrants from Italy Greece and the
Slavic lands forced to leave the company
houses in which they were living they
created a tent colony and stayed in it
through the winter
despite bitter temperatures in the
Sangre de Cristo Mountains the company
responded by hiring armed men and
calling out the state militia and a
tense standoff ensued as the strikers
tried to prevent a new generation of
strike breakers from taking their jobs
on April the 20th 1914 the militia fired
a machine gun into the tent colony and
set fire to it at least 30 people were
killed including two women and 11
children asphyxiated by smoke in a
cellar under one of the tents enraged
workers retaliated attacking company
property and militiamen through
the region killing dozens more and
suffering more casualties in return this
was probably the most violent episode on
American soil since the Battle of the
Little Bighorn in 1876 finally President
Woodrow Wilson intervened by sending a
regiment of the United States cavalry to
the area to restore peace the
Congressional hearings that followed
depicted john d rockefeller owner of the
colorado fuel and iron company in a very
unfavorable light Rockefeller had
already been singled out as an
unscrupulous robber baron by the
muckraking journalist Ida Tarbell eager
to repair his reputation and to win
renown for philanthropy rather than
brutality Rockefeller belatedly ordered
the company to improve wages and
conditions at Ludlow instituting an
eight-hour day an outlawing child labor
from this distance it's difficult to
imagine how volatile industrial
workplaces could be in the early 20th
century the workers were enraged at bad
conditions low pay
unscrupulous treatment by their bosses
and chronic insecurity in danger at the
workplace
the owners meanwhile were usually in
tough competition with each other and
shared a common threat from the union's
knowing that some of the Union men would
not hesitate to take direct action they
resisted by hiring labor spies
infiltrators as Jean provocateur and by
using Pinkerton detectives to intimidate
or assault the leaders when Harrison
gray Otis editor of the Los Angeles
Times refused to let his own workforce
unionize and when he published strong
anti-union editorials to radical labor
activists the McNamara brothers
responded by dynamiting the offices of
the newspaper in 1910 killing 21 people
and injuring a hundred more they tried
to kill Otis himself but the bomb they
planted at his home failed to explode
again the case attracted influential men
on both sides including Clarence Darrow
Lincoln Steffens a famous socialist
writer of the era and Eugene Debs
leader of the American Socialist Party
Deb's was more or less obliged to
concede that the McNamara brothers were
guilty but he wrote that the oppressive
conditions of American capitalism had
forced them to take desperate measures
as this brief survey of violence in the
American West shows it was a place where
conflict could erupt suddenly among men
preoccupied with their honor and their
reputation for bravery men who were well
armed and exposed to danger in a newly
settled environment the feeling that
they were being cheated either by
thieves or by rivals for the land by
Chinese immigrants or by industrial
bosses could lead quickly to escalating
violence members of the American elite
did not regard this propensity for
violence as an entirely bad thing since
they too valued the code of bravery and
honor when Theodore Roosevelt raised his
regiment the Rough Riders in 1898 for
the war against Spain in Cuba he
recruited cowboys Indians and sheriff's
men he'd known from his days as a Dakota
wrench man some of our best recruits
came from Colorado he wrote one a very
large hawk-eyed man Benjamin Franklin
Daniel's had been marshal of Dodge City
when that pleasing town was probably the
toughest abode of civilized man to be
found anywhere on the continent
naturally he viewed the dangers of
battle with philosophic calm readiness
to fight what Roosevelt called manliness
seemed to him the essential antidote to
an America that was in danger of losing
the martial virtues and becoming soft on
the other hand certain factors prevented
western violence from ever becoming
chronic the area never deteriorated into
civil war one of these factors was the
tradition of due process already very
strong in American life if the memory of
Lexington and Concord made Americans
willing to reach for their guns the
memory of the founding fathers made them
equally willing to seek legal solutions
to their problems nearly all of them
were literate nearly all were familiar
with filing a claim at the land office
or registering town lots and nearly all
regarded violence only as a fallback
when law appeared inadequate the sheer
size and scale of the West also tempted
men in conflicts to move rather than
stay and fight risking their own lives
and those of their families taking the
long view we should be more impressed by
this willingness to submit to the law
and to cooperate than by the colorful
but transient phases of frontier
lawlessness